torahler gang second shows have been
added to Austin Connecticut Vermont and
Tampa tickets are on sale get those
tickies now yeah baby we're also coming
to Oklahoma City Dallas Texas Houston
Texas uh uh Dania Beach Florida Raleigh
North Carolina just added Louisville
Kentucky we got Cleveland Ohio and
Columbus Ohio this is just the first
light get those tickets before they sell
out we'll see out on the road welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it at the group to be classy
or if they're just a big O piece of
trash I'm your host Dave trolley coming
at you on a Monumental day down here in
Aunt tudy's basement construction is
done completed audition is put on the
back of the house it's a big boy and
here's the good news what's that we're
allowed to record up there she's got to
join all back down for us nice carpet it
looks fantastic next week we're going to
be coming at you from the new edition
baby
that place looks expensive the boys are
crawling out in a basement finally get
you a little color a little salt I'm at
sea level I'm back to sea level down
here like a mole one of the subway
people I got the bends from being down
here so much put you in the chamber gang
next week we're gonna be coming at you
from the brand new edition out back at
Toadies come by and see us it's going to
be a good [__] time yeah my co-host
is coming at you from across the table
he is the CEO of are you garbage he is
an international businessman he's
Abraham Lincoln because he's leading us
to the promised land
oh baby they doubted you and look at you
now kid who doubted me what are you
talking about is that what you and
T-Bone have been doing behind my back
you [__] yeah give it up for KJ
Kevin James
Mr Ryan now what's up gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rate if you subscribe
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are
and then obviously yeah now more than
ever the greatest gosh darn website of
all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you go
over there you get bonus episodes ayg
you get the runaway hit of hard feelings
baby
aka the goddamn Thunder though uh they
get all the bonus videos we've done we
can do monthly Vlogs of us on the road
the whole nine yards check it out it's a
good time game it's a good time gang
come over and hang out with us and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire to the Magic Man
sure makes us all look good uh-huh works
the ones works the twos crosses the t's
and that's the eyes T-Bone mcgruffins
Toby McMullen everybody
uh now's probably a good time to tell
you about the class action lawsuit for
all the black mold we've been giving
people down here
yeah this place ain't up to code by the
way there's a goddamn sump pump haven't
worked in 10 years water heaters leaking
there's Ritz I found a whole rant my
podcast my shoes are wet down here
yeah this place smells yeah
I think I got The Black Lung boss I
smell like mothballs walking around yeah
um how you boys doing pretty good
no you freak out sometimes you know what
I've recently discovered that's very
very classy that just came into the
Foley household I'm listening
what do you guys got cooking now over
there you've been using towels this
whole time
um the automatic oh salt and pepper a
grinder
whoa yeah oh what's that set you back
not too bad actually got no idea the
bird got it I didn't even think about
that can't be more than 20 bucks how
hard is grinding pepper not hard anymore
I can tell you that it's easy with the
touch of one bucket [__] it's
impressive a button's like turning a
lamp on Ah that's not bad you're gonna
sit electric salt and pepper shaker 20
bucks out the door heavy bike now real
classy question what kind of salt you
got in there we don't use that Himalayan
salt no more it's no good for you what
are you talking about it's all
microplastics most of it's rock candy
I got blueberry
which I was a huge fan of as a kid no oh
you like candy as a fat little guy
running around blueberry you ever make
your own rock candy no I'm not a [__]
meth head we thought who makes their own
rock candy go to the store like a
[__] gentleman they don't sell it
anymore dude hillbilly [__] oh rock
candy right they sell it no they don't
that's real you gotta find that in like
a country store you catch that on your
way out of a Cracker Barrel or something
I'd never been in a country store I
don't think and I've bought rock candy
before I have it in jars they used to
have candy shops Corner Store bow
diggers there's not one piece of rock
candy in a bodega in New York City
that's Amish [__] well yeah well I was
joking about bodegas but they have them
at [__] candy stores and [__] really
yeah I've bought it it was hard to find
when I was a kid do you know what I'm
talking about it looks like Chris
[__] [__] did we just turn into
[__] hippies and [__] out I ain't
talking about no Snickers [__]
talking about artisanal we've just been
talking about rock candy for three
minutes and now you're checking to see
if I know the only place I knew to get
it was the was the Franklin Institute
and I always made sure I had a couple of
shekels on me when we went down for the
field trip yeah that's the first thing I
would do is go right to the gift shop
get my hands on some rock candy man why
I'm walking through the big heart yeah
checking out the planetarium or whatever
it was yeah I used to love it and we
made it in uh we made it in school yeah
I remember you can make it put it on the
stick or whatever put like a string and
all that stuff they tried to do it with
salt [__] out of here with that yeah
make with the sugar I never liked making
anything on my own no I told you about I
had a babysitter trying to make us make
ice cream [__] kick Rock oh it's that
was her last day
hey Ma she touched me get her out of
here I ain't [__] you put like cream
in a in an ice in a coffee can and
rolled around she's like it'll be fun I
was like you know what would be fun to
try to show acne with a little Butter
Brickle yeah you know it'll be fun of
[__] an ice cream sandwich right now
not waiting [__] eight to ten hours
to make my own you dumb broad I know the
peace left you at 20. yeah [__] get
Uber Eats on the phone get some Sherby
over here stat I don't have time to make
my own [__] dessert but we don't [__]
with the Himalayan salt no more okay I
think it's uh it's kind of a bust
I don't know and what's that I mean what
promises is it making you I think a lot
of it is fake it's not real Himalayan
salt okay
yeah okay I don't know if it's
Vietnamese
all right yeah I don't know Italian not
even Himalayan I don't even know enough
about it the problem with the electric
salt and pepper shakers it's a slippery
slope why because now you got to get one
of those big old wooden parmesan cheese
graters
you know what was real trash is any time
you have like the huge utensils on the
wall like in the kitchen as decoration
or something did you ever see those like
a big wooden spoon that would be like
this big and a fork on the wall that you
use the stir we have those no no it's
decoration oh like oh yeah it's like a
size of an ore you know what I mean it's
like a broom you're pulling spoons off
the wall like swords yeah
someone breaks in this is a Natori hanzu
I only stir my meat sauce no we never
had that [__] we didn't have any no we
didn't have it I'm just saying I
remember going to people's houses and
being like what the [__] yeah we also
didn't I would always fake eat cereal
with it it's a good time that's a bit
we didn't Patty didn't trust the um
government the wooden
she didn't we didn't have like The
Wooden Spoon set on the counter she was
always metal she didn't trust those for
some reason they were never out that's
that's on the counter that's a Next
Generation thing but you know they have
like the wooden the you know the like a
wooden Ladle uh-huh like a wooden Ladle
yeah like a wooden spoon that you would
like that's different than a ladle they
have a label it would be a set that'd be
like a pasta thing or this and that a
spatula
never had that she's like let's get
they're dirty we had one for we had one
one of a regular wooden looking spoon
for sauce or whatever yeah she didn't go
for that well we just had one and that
thing turns dark and black and green it
got everything in it yeah now we were a
metal fan for sure he wasn't doing that
old school [__] [__] give me
stainless steel Colonial Williamsburg
[__] [__] on your turn and butter
goddamn wooden spoon with [__]
Detroit Steel on [__] cast iron yeah
I want a part of a Ford bumper get a
little iron in the diet you know what I
mean yeah yeah we just picked that up
man thing's all right that's pretty cool
using a lot of pepper these days though
I'll tell you that yeah it's funny you
go heavy bike yeah it's like getting a
snow blower I'll give you that that's
pretty [__] classy yeah that's all
right man not bad that's another one of
those things in my head of like that's
awesome I'll never own one of those I
was like a pizza cutter to me that's 19
bucks on Amazon I can have it I could be
[__] putting fresh salt and pepper on
my Eggies tomorrow morning dude telling
you do yourself a favor
that's pretty all right yeah clean
living baby oh look at you yeah that was
her idea now no it was my idea yeah no
you're an idea man sometimes no
she saw it somewhere showed up at the
house and what the [__] is this thought
it was a new vibrator all right hey
we're gonna freaking know how you doing
I'm not around you need two of them
you ever see the at the restaurants
where they have the giant wheel of
cheese and they set it on fire and they
mix up the pasta and they've never been
to it but I've seen it on on the
Instagram there it seems a little dirty
to be honest with you I can see that in
your crib
[Laughter]
wheel going
like you're in a goddamn Swiss Alps
that seems a little janky to me to be
honest how do they clean that they don't
well you can't clean cheese that's what
I'm saying bro you don't run it through
a dishwasher
that's what I'm saying yeah they don't I
wonder if they they probably scrape a
layer off or something like that I don't
know I mean you've worked there it's
still walls
it tastes like SOS pads yeah I'm not a
big fan of that just just a [__]
cheese on it in a bowl yeah I don't like
that's uh I don't like all this Broadway
[__] I don't like the theatrics give me
a [__] piece of steak on a plane yeah
the Salt Bay guy I told you I went yeah
I try to we're gonna it's me and my wife
in a [__] goddamn empty restaurant
this guy's feeding my wife like he's
about to make a move on her he's lucky I
didn't [__] tune them up with a one
too here you told me get out of here
with that [__] overpriced [__]
[__] yeah putting gold on stuff you
wearing sunglasses at night you [__]
you put a collared shirt on in the
goddamn restaurant will you yeah I don't
want your [__] pubes in my [__] in
my mashed potatoes here buddy the [__]
shave that mustache and lose the pony
daily set us up with a couple of lava
cakes
uh
uh yeah I don't go for that stuff man I
was somewhere uh I didn't even trust the
Fogo de Chow places I don't really know
what's the rule they're trashy right
a Fogo de Chao has to be trashy videos
you went down to Argentina went to like
a legit dropper yeah I mean that's a big
chain Buffet is a buffet as far as I'm
concerned yeah and they had one in
Philly I don't trust these [__] pill
heads [__] cutting meat right in
front of me some dirt ball Wheeling the
[__] going at you
what's up Ollie bringing a wheelbarrow
or a [__] stake over to the table
slicing it up yeah I don't maybe it's
good though the buffet I never got and
like I mean I think like what what do
you mean that's not a buffet but it's
just never ending it's all you can eat
yeah don't start talking [__] about a
hot Buffet they're fantastic listen we
get in this all the time I don't
understand how you don't understand I'm
not saying they're not great but buffets
are trashy sure they're great I love a
buffet I'll [__] go down I'll eat
mashed potato I'll cause I'll do
everything I love a hot bar I love it
all
um yeah anywhere that's architecture is
based on the ability for a rascal
scooter to navigate it there's no good
flow of people is is rough when you're
[__] Cece if your restaurant has a
cover charge it's a tough one all right
cc's is a real tough look
that pizza joint yeah I went it [__]
sucked I went in at State College it
feels real weird walking through that
line yeah I'm half eating pizzas yeah
then there's like a Nutella one at the
end yeah I had a cinnamon one cotton and
I used to bang out uh rubies the
all-you-can-eat Chinese buffet down
there on Delaware Ave I think it was
that place next to the Halloween store
in Philly that was a stripper store it's
cute of you to call it a Halloween store
that was a Halloween store for about
three weeks a year it was right next to
uh they're 49 it was a who's Delilah's
right uh right down the street from uh
daydream no show and talents they were
all they're all down there yeah on the
water yeah there they are easier to
throw the bodies when you did a show in
them show and tell yeah I wasn't sure
until it was Delilah's that wasn't
Delilah's a positive was Delilah's I
will bet you any amount of money was not
Delilah Delilah's is on
uh it was down by the movie theater I
thought where warmdaddies was yeah
that's not Delilah's no no it was Club
risque yes that's what it was yeah
yeah come hang out we had like done
something like come hang out I'm like
all right I don't know I don't know I
didn't know how comedy worked I walked
in I'm like what a [__] strip club
dude are you picking up money off
something there's about three people
there I left and the one guy was getting
a lap dance I left before it started
yeah it was a tough I'm not I was about
a [__] hour into comedy and I'm like
this
this dude don't know what the [__] he's
doing he's talking a big game he's
talking a big game and the only guy in
the audience has a boner right now I'm
leaving ah gang it's a gosh darn Family
episode as you know when you sign up for
patreon we will answer your question on
the air you choose shout out to Mr
mersey
um we got a A lot of people submit email
text the whole night knock on my door
got the questions patreon gets first
crack at it because they're the goddamn
homies
uh this one's from Michael Clark is it
garbage to have cans of paint and wood
stains in a garage or attic from the
previous tenant that's so funny man
every house we've ever bought had [__]
left over in it yeah I've always every
time I've left I've left something yeah
I don't need that stain what if they
want to touch up the doors yeah I'm gone
always leave you never use it but it's
there for 30 years oh yeah the house we
moved into Wilkes-Barre from Mountaintop
there was toys downstairs in the
basement
they went into the rotation yeah and it
was it was an unfinished basement too
looking back on it it was weird it's an
unfinished basement and there was a
bunch of like you know like like uh like
animal toy like a gorilla and this and
that in the corner
down there chained up evil Bart Simpsons
[__] [__] up uh that reminds me we
had a unfinished basement uh in the
house for a long time then when then
went to semi-finished trash and then I
think when they got
it was getting finished and I don't know
if we ran out of money there was always
that part or the divorce basement was
done then you'd peek around the corner
like oh what the [__] not even that the
whole thing was halfway done
the whole thing was never finished like
the one wall the one room was painted
one color another one another caller oh
no we did have an office they did the
computer room first yeah I've been in
there yeah that was slot machine in
there there is a slot machine in there
step right up step right in one and wins
any prize and he died I'm gonna give his
Casino the house never loses need your
ID gentlemen
it'll be three goldfish to enter
um
but then we had the I remember I want to
say it was a uh it had to be like a
communion party we finished it for the
party and I remember even being then I'm
like this seems not right
that we're finishing you know up that's
our major project that's how [__] gets
done in order to have people come over
and that's how all that the only way
[__] got done at the Foley houses if
somebody was coming to [__] over haven't
come to keep up the [__] facade that
we were a normal American happy family
which we were not I remember my dad
crazy we didn't have chairs for
something we'd be like my dad my dad
moved around like you know place to
place a little bit uh we didn't have
chairs when we were having people over
something I remember we had to go by
like chat like Furniture you know like
actual to keep up appearances of that
word of a working household of some sort
we were having people over for like a
it's like a party when your parents come
back from the weekend everything's
sliding into places they open the door
that's exactly what it was you're like
ripping plastic off a bar stool or
something
putting vhs's on your shelf to look like
you're a learned doctor yeah we got this
about four years ago you're still
setting up the TV that's out of it's
auto program is because everyone had
used to count through oh man that was
that technology blew me away I
understand I was like it's got to run
through all of them someone knows what's
what that's what I was like telling
myself yeah uh that and I remember that
there was a time
when you know what I don't know if it
was like the technology of the gaming it
was like a Sega or an N64 whatever
but we would have to we weren't able to
flip it over in the back
no you have to really we'd have to hook
it in and then unhook it if that makes
sense like you couldn't watch TV with 64
set up
in my room yeah to unhook yeah unscrew
the [__] again
yeah but then I remember some kids had
it both and I'm like they had a circle
like just flipped a video or four I'm
like what God damn we [__] NASA
technology the Atari had a thing in the
back that you had to that you had to
flip over too otherwise Atari was free
way way before my time Atari that was
our first system probably 19. that was
the first system 90 weird if you had
something before that
the Foley's at The Cutting Edge of video
game technology
got a PlayStation in 1978. uh this is
probably
82 83 got an Atari Space Invaders
Pitfall and something called Target
where it was different
you were tanks but real bad tanks okay I
assumed yeah and there was a couple
different things to it old man used to
get out of there ripped some heaters and
get all the [__] Space Invaders of my
brother really oh yeah your dad played
that was the last time Tucker that was
the first and last time Terry Foley ever
played a video game was 1982 he had a
[__] hot summer on Space Invaders
I'll give you that I did real good too I
don't think my dad would even
it was one button it's true and he was
probably when he he was probably 23 or
24. yeah [__] baby my dad never
touched a video game my brother on the
other hand I had to lose him on purpose
because if I won he'd hit me with the
controller yeah like his style I've
broken some controllers in my day for
sure oh you [__] what I've never done
that [__] start freaking out slamming
the controllers around I wasn't that big
into the video game yeah that's why he
didn't do it and I said no a video game
and anybody even if you're a casual
player
it will bring out a frustration in you
that's primitive it's it's PRI it's not
you're a nerd it's [__] it's just
it's losing it's frustration it's not
being able to do it it's [__] fail
it's oh yeah [__] dude playing Matt
dude when Madden dropped on PS2 we were
in oh PS2 we were in on that [__]
started with Sega yeah it was Madden 93
or 92 or whatever was the first one but
he used to play him on Sega play that
play the college one and [__] hockey
was big we did get into that yeah what
am I talking about we did play a lot of
video games we played the sports ones
yeah I think it got hockey was great
when they got the guy's head open well
they got more realistic I think is when
the emotion really got [__] charged
up in it you know what I mean when
you're actually [__] running routes
you're not a little square guy with a
helmet [__] hopping along the field
I'm a Tecmo Bowl man just run the other
way this episode is brought to you by
better help uh-huh gang we all got
problems yep I'm crazy as they come me
too baby it's a good idea to talk to
somebody sometimes you can't find the
right person to talk to in your local
area yes so what you could do is go
someone better help licensed therapist
tons of different Specialties yep
privacy your own home
yeah uh I I'm a I'm a client of better
help I think it's fantastic I think talk
therapy in general is fantastic
everybody keeps everything bottled up
you got to talk to somebody you gotta
get it out there baby you got to take
that first little step to change uh if
you need to switch therapists and you
can make the change at no additional
charge it's convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule uh discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com garbage today to get 10
off your first month one more time baby
that's 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash garbage I'm gonna
write it down take it take take control
of your life baby better help
help.com garbage do it factor factor
give me the news I got a microwave for
cooking you okay all right yeah you like
that T-Bone doing a little Factor promo
here guys I can't tell you enough how
delicious how nutritious the factor
meals are my only problem is I eat like
two or three they're so delicious each
12 of them a day because I love them
they're fantastic they're good man I'm
telling you straight up they're good I
get them delivered every Wednesday at a
crib I got the the birds eating them
she's like oh order the chicken taco
bowl for me well because you go and you
get to customize your order yeah all
right I'm all at the past two weeks dude
I've been all Heavy by chili and taco
bowls hippies
stay in regularly I'm keeping it oh you
were going there guys uh you saved time
with Factor America's number one ready
to eat meal kit that's delivered
straight to your door meals are fresh
never Frozen they're dirty in just two
minutes I throw it on a pan for two
seconds you don't need nothing that's
classy too I usually put it in the
microwave because it takes it takes two
minutes on a microwave and it's ready to
go and it's evenly cooked a pan that's
nice they got the sauce it keeps it
keeps it moist you don't have to use oil
or nothing that's pretty classic you
throw it on a plate dinner you put it
back on the factor box
what you throw it on the plate I put it
if it's a chili or something I put in
the bowl of Toby what do you do
whoa
[Laughter]
that's so trashy dude all right we're
gonna talk about that that's why I like
microwaving them
because it's all right there hold on I
gotta get through this read and then
we're gonna fist fight uh if you're
vegan vegetarian keto or counting
calories Factor has a plan for you
prepared by chefs and approved by
dietitians
you'll find a plan you'll love head to
factorymheel.com garbage50 and use code
garbage 50 to get 50 off your first box
50 they're giving it away that's code
garbage that's code garbage 50 at
factormeels.com garbage trip to get 50
off your first box do it save me some
Tuscan meatballs how did they [__] that
up did you know that in Tecmo ball you
could run the other way and you would
keep going
I don't know you could like just keep
dropping back and dropping back and
dropping back I think unless that was on
truth I might have been tripping balls I
don't know I was dropping acid and
dropping acid and dropping ass drop an
ass and dropping it backwards with Dan
Marino uh
uh let's see here this one's from Drew
ten dollar homie is it garbage to go on
dates and play ayg using all the Kippy
and Foley's jokes pretending that you
created the game on your own in order to
get laid worked a couple of times thanks
boys
shout out to you happy to help in any
way I can someone's got to get their
little wiener wet oh my God Hachi machi
oh my God that's fun yeah you say Hachi
Machi so so what you're into do you like
what do you do for a living that's funny
yes what I do for a living have you ever
yeah still waiting for global
distribution right now but I think it's
a million dollar idea what oh his game
he's got her back at his mom's house
he's like I can give you 10 of the game
for well game I came up with are you
garbage don't Google it yeah it's a lot
of fun some guys ripped me off I'd even
respect that say we ripped you off like
the McDonald's Brothers
get a little sob story Ray Crocks us
yeah
I respect it though didn't the guy who
invented the windshield wiper that
happened to what what was the the movie
with um that's a movie
God damn don't make anything
it was with so there it was it was a
monsoon I couldn't see it was like we've
got Greg Kinnear Flash of Genius
it was the guy who invented something
and got screwed over by the car
companies
I could be wrong steering wheels no no
you're right flasher genius Robert
Kearns takes on the Detroit automakers
who he claims stole the his idea for the
intermittent windshield wiper there you
go
before they would just wipe their hand
I've done that [__] leaning out
trying to get ice off you know this
movie sucks because the description of
it repeats though it's about windshield
wipers man I don't know if it sucks well
the second sentence is the first
sentence again it just literally says
Robert Kern stinks on Detroit automakers
Eclipse it was a nervous guy in the
elevator pitch what do you want
don't make bad movies know what his best
is a little movie called The Matador
with Pierce Bronson
got a little couple couple hours do
yourself a couple of hours I promise you
will love it Brosnan Brosnan yeah you
didn't say that right what'd I say
brajnan Russian here's Bronson Pierce
Bronson Charles Pierce Bronson I love
him Remington Steele he was back in the
day that would be my poor name Remington
Steele really sure I thought it would be
little dick Guy
step right up step right in
bring tiny over here uh hmm all right
let's see here let's get Bitcoin trick
uh this is when Jack ever left priority
tags on your checked bag to show off and
then in parentheses it was a free
upgrade
keeping the lift ticket on your jacket I
respect it yeah yeah yeah Floyd you
gotta Flex a little on these bows that's
all right show them what's what
priority grab somebody's first class
boarding pass probably the same guy with
the cards yeah he's got everybody
everything he's [__] she's pulling
the wool over everybody's eyes and I've
as an international businessman I
respect oh dude that's so funny uh I
like that it's worked a couple of times
what can I get no maybe yeah yeah good
for him hey whatever works works what
the homies to succeed let's go
yeah I mean first dates are mostly
questions yeah no for sure I mean people
have said that they did they they do it
on first dates they're on like pulls out
Battleship you're not gonna believe this
I think six yeah I think I'm gonna call
it clue what do you think
it's like Monopoly
the guy doesn't have a monocle there's a
great shout out David Phillips Great
Chicago comic who had a joke because you
guys are playing Cold Case it's when
you're too poor to afford all the pieces
for Clues you'll have enough to commit
the crime and not solve it oh that's a
lot of fun it's funny I remember there
was a couple of times that I was playing
clue with my mom we got like into it for
like a a week or something I was
probably seven or something like my
brother would go out of the house
and like I was like stuck like if they
were doing something on like a Saturday
night going to like a friend's house or
the mall or whatever sure I was stuck
home yeah and we played clue I remember
being like this is a [__] pretty
gruesome game to be [__] playing with
a seven-year-old
this is why I remember somebody somebody
getting murdered in a pool house with a
lead bike yeah with a monkey wrench I
mean games are cartoons or something we
can watch the [__] lady
she always did love True Crime what were
the weapons the weapons rope revolver a
rope what the [__] I know dude it's real
gruesome revolver all right
gentleman's Gap
uh lead pipe rope candlestick
uh knife knife wrench you gotta really
beat this Sawzall
chainsaw
needle nose pliers
hot dose of heroin what the [__]
you like Sharon Stone and casino uh yeah
that's uh I was gruesome we never played
Monopoly ever were you a monopoly
household I now thinking about I think
it's because we were
there was very highs and lows of money
issues so I think you want to rubs in
your face yeah I think it was very like
uh when the Foley's play we were living
Monopoly when the foleys play everyone
ends up in death
we didn't really you guys end up
squatting houses and stuff we were more
of a Shoots and Ladders fan yeah
that was like it was too much it was too
much a banker yeah my dad was always he
was just all had 20s just [__]
banging everybody Candyland what are we
Mensa I used to love Candyland fat
little bit I wanted to live there sit
there and stare at the board that was my
speed life I didn't like either seems
too serious I thought I had thought I
was getting put in a pen
give me life driving around that little
car with a bunch of little Rugrats some
dumb horror I knocked up
no I gotta oh I'm stuck with her working
a [__] shitty nine to five get the
[__] out of here
where's where's the card where I live it
up with the boys
oh man go down to Tijuana for a bachelor
party
crash the car
yeah we didn't [__] with that [__] nah
that was never uh that or chess we're a
Checkers family oh Checkers all day yeah
I didn't meet somebody who could play
chess until I was in my 30s
I swear to God yeah no we nobody I knew
played [__] chess there was a summer
like maybe going into senior year I
might have been one in somebody's house
but that was the show yeah no I think
flip
dad knew and flip kinda like his
grandfather he knew some movements they
try to teach him I just know the one can
move like two up and three oh that's the
only thing yeah and I'll still say
people go you play Jessica kinda you
know kind again as long as I as long as
I know there's not a board around
as long as there's not a board in a
fight me [__]
what
yeah we were uh checkers
also there's a I'm sure I mentioned it a
very shitty version between Checkers and
chess
that's it's a little Stratego
it's a little like gay like a little uh
I remember that [__] it's for dorks but
me me and uh me and Pat got into it one
summer like eighth grade or whatever
when he you don't have a car you can't
really go anywhere so you're just like
jammed up for a couple hours in
someone's house till someone's coming
Stratego the amount of times that board
must have gotten flipped over between
the two of you oh yeah for sure we had
this game uh
we had this game that we got from our
cousins our older our older cousins that
I think it was left over from the 70s
it was a flat white
uh board
and you had these little metal balls
that had little like red or blue like
rings around them you had a rubber band
and it went up and it bounced and you
had to get it back the other way without
going off the board
I don't know what it was called but that
was a good time I don't know until we
started pegging each other with them
sure that was the same thing with
Crossfire when that [__] marketing
dropped crossed fire yeah shooting the
[__] ball bearings like [__] we
started me and Danny were winging those
at each other getting in fights in the
[__] in the dining room [__]
winging them that was a good time that
was sport always sucked too like they'd
all like settle in the middle because
like the it was like a piece of shitty
like particle sure you know like reach
and get there was never that hungry
hungry hippos ah that was my speed I
loved hungry hungry the board game where
you eat no way Hungry Hungry Hippos was
a good time and we used to play a game
it was similar to mousetrap called The
Flying Finnegans
they were a circus act and you had to
get you had to flip the guy in over a
thing right yeah like over the shark or
something like that I can't remember
never I don't even think we ever
attempted to set it up no I mean I think
I just like played with the pieces
I remember asking my mom's like yeah we
don't do that
this guy's eating the hotel
yeah no I never uh we did have the
Fisher Price
pool Billiards ping pong and basketball
that's just a good time fool man yeah I
was gonna cross some [__] up
[__] give him the old [__] Shimmy
Shake I was like [__] hot sauce out
there baby with the juice box
what was Uncle Mike's move the bread and
butter the bread with the bread and
butter there you go
got it Ah that's good stuff look out
look out
um
all right this one's from Casey
uh are you garbage if you take a loan
from Credit Karma to pay for your boob
job
huh
okay I had to zoom in on the picture it
was pretty cool really
yeah do your thing yeah I respect it uh
that's what rich people do rich people
don't spend their money they spend other
people's money so why not who you been
talking to a couple of people I don't
like this it's what they do they'll be
pitching me business ideas pretty soon
you get boob job Hey listen I need a
boob hey hey can't be I need 10 grand I
gotta get my tits done I want to get my
nuts bigger breast reduction Maybe
I was pitching ideas to Toby downstairs
oh what were they anything good what
business ideas no
nothing
we can't say publicly man what are you
gonna do is steal my idea we already got
this guy running around ripping us off
to gaboon hey it's like a Dairy Queen
but no the New York should have um
cold plunge and sauna places where it's
just that
mm-hmm that's all I got all right I'll
get on it I'll put my good team on it
get them figuring that out for you
me and you traded the topic Doug is that
was that is that gonna be your out of uh
is that Gonna Be Your Side Biz because
you're gonna have to start to diversify
at some point it's gonna be too much to
do we were saying that that's too much
overhead
oh yeah that's a you learned that you
gotta buy all that [__] rent a space
build up The Client List you'd have to
do you have to be able to do it
affordable uh-huh and you know timely
and keep it clean and stuff like that
maybe you need like six seven beds
something okay I don't know cold plunges
for the common man cold plunges for the
Common Man call it Duncan chunkin
nothing all right
just my ball in here just
no such thing as a bad idea okay
call it Duncan cold nuts
no
Duncan your partner's out on the name
get on Shark Tank the funding just got
pulled I'm so sorry get on Shark Tank
start from the ground up
getting business with uh Lori what's
your name
Lori yeah she's all right man you know
what I wouldn't mind taking a crack at
Barb either you've said that before all
right she's probably a [__] freak in
the sheets
that you say that about a pillar of
Industry like that she's always making
sense they're making sex jokes about her
on there she's always hitting on the
[__] eye candy like the [__] hot
dudes that come in the hot dudes that
rolling with the Izod shirt yeah hello
sharks yeah that are like if there's if
it's [__] out of my face [__] give
me the [__] money Cuban
you got it I know you got it piece of
[__]
coughing up I mean if that's not just
like this that's a show that's my
favorite show right now oh I love it I I
don't know when I'm watching it from too
so I can never tell if it's a good idea
or not because I don't know if it's from
15 years ago I'm doing up you can take
him in and Pitch something that
everybody has like what the [__]
everybody's got that [__] now and you
find out it was something like 2003.
yeah yeah okay let's talk about pretty
litter pretty because you know I'm a
kitty cat man and T-Bone's a kitty cat
man yeah and there's nothing more that
you care about in this world more than
your little kitty cats I love hunting
Ponzi hansie Ponzi don't need kitty
litter nope and if he did you know what
he would use he'd use pretty little you
want to know why here's the coolest
thing it changes color if it detects an
illness in the pet I tested it out
myself pre-menopausal
[Laughter]
gang do yourself a favor pretty little
is smart it's effective yep it smells
great and it's good for the animals yes
uh pretty litters like Crystal base also
minimizes mess smell and dust you'll
have to you get to keep it realize that
animals you get to keep it you get to
keep a clean home and have peace of mind
pretty litter helps keep tabs on your
cat's health and keeps odors down you
get you and your cat are going to love
pretty litter as much as the big man and
you're I brought that [__] the bird
didn't know that I that we that they
became a sponsor and that they sent us
some I brought that into the house she's
like whoa where'd you get that yeah
swear to God I know it's a it's a good
product go to prettyloader.com garbage
and save 20 on your first order that's
pretty little.com slash garbage to save
20 pretty litter.com garbage terms and
conditions apply Cipher details now back
to the show
that's like such a a that's a show that
would be on
like The Simpsons showing the future you
know what I mean hey poor people come
tap dance to see if these billionaires
give you cash that they don't need you
know what I mean and then they'll fight
over you it's like [__]
you know there was one lady that got
like 750 grand out of them two of them
teamed up they do that a lot Mr
Wonderful and somebody else they do that
a lot it was a lady the [__] did she
sell
and well it was sunlight it was uh damn
how'd you package that the [__] yeah it
was like some kind of light that gives
you uh like vitamin D and yeah whatever
like a heat lamp type something yeah
gotcha uh speaking of TV TV shows this
one for Matthew is it garbage to watch
Jeopardy call out the answers out loud
in your living room
I don't think anyone in my family ever
knew one answer oh dude we tried we
didn't even turn it on Jeopardy with
Jeopardy was big in our house believe it
or not we're just kind of waiting around
to A Wheel of Fortune started yeah we
were played the action we were a Sajak
fan for sure he went for the money baby
but eye candy if you caught that 15
minutes before if you got to the TV
early and then as my dad started to you
know his you know the dementia set in
they would have him do that just to like
you know
mm-hmm
the joke I was gonna go with is where am
I oh I was I was gonna go with what is
happening to me
no it was like the doctor said like you
know it was like like a brain thing sure
sit down sharp yeah yeah
yeah no we would uh he wasn't getting
too many right at that point
but he was trying there's Maybe
how many what it was all right who
invented the elevator what is it New
Jersey
shout out to him shout out to him uh I
don't think I would only ever get like
the pop culture ones that I you know
like
I'm a DMX or whatever I could sneak a
couple a couple history you're pretty
good at yeah I would be
yeah hit me with a couple unless it's
Seinfeld stuff no
oh that's a good hard feelings though we
do Jeopardy and see who gets the best
score yeah that's not bad damn hit us
one or two just to see
go history no pick the ones I know of
food
Dr Pepper was invented in
what is 1963. you're sipping one
I'm reading the bottle
uh all right what T-Bone's doing it
let's move a m this one's from Captain
Lou yeah is it garbage to wear an
airplane neck pillow at home in your own
bed or couch
yeah man I would say they're [__]
trashy all together they're never clean
he might be jammed up with a neck
problem though
I think you're all right I think he
would lean he would say that there I
have a neck problem he's just being a
dirt bike he's just be [__] sitting
in his house not one though doesn't like
he's gonna goddamn neck brace yeah I
don't like him uh-uh I never they've
never come on a plane in my eyes they
have to be really big because I'm still
leaning too much yeah I need like a
[__] net do you prop me up like that
I'd be chilling that's a tough sleep on
your side if I get like dude in the back
seat you feel the strain already yeah
that ain't [__] good you don't want
to be doing that
um all right let's see this one's from
Mike uh
uh have you ever forgotten your own
birthday
that's tough I'm too the actual birthday
never no I'm [__] waiting my family
has yeah my dad what are you Molly
Ringwald never got your birthday nah my
dad oh my God you struck out with the
cute guy in school uh no you well you
text on your will you call your brother
on his birthday say happy birthday you
shoot a text hey happy birthday cool
everybody gets a call everybody gets a
call my cousins if my mom reminds me or
like a couple cousins I know just
because we're real close in age they'll
get a text happy birthday whatever you
know maybe one year we're doing
something or whatever
um but immediate fam you know my mom
brother sister-in-law and the kids
yeah it calls kids are get kids get to
FaceTime calls at dinner usually
it's funny when we went to see uh I'm
saying yeah no if you're not able to see
them what I'm asking what the form of
communication well we went out to see my
dad's headstone all right it was right
after my birthday okay because I was
away on my birthday
and
we go to dinner
dinner's winding down desserts ordered
okay dessert hits the table no candle
for the big guy whoa pissed
pissed but the waitress just forgot it
and she came back out with just a little
Ramekin filled with whipped cream in a
candle tried to start singing I put the
kibosh on that I was like splits well
you would be upset if they didn't put a
candle [__] right okay I'm a [__]
Dirtbag when it comes to that stuff I
know I know give me gimme and if the
cash was like when I was younger
I'd be upset
I am my uncle making Aunt Colleen used
to come in heavy but yeah yeah finny
boom yeah yeah straighten me the [__]
out and Kate would always grease me with
a hundo
dude my godmother though and she's got a
little bit of cash there you go yeah my
aunt Colleen was my godmother uh but
that like I think I said too like I
really leverage my birthday gifts months
in advance
yeah me too you know what I mean I need
a new bike or a new skateboard or
something she's like all right we're
[__] weasels what do you mean I can
play in the game no he's Sweeting the
other day off with something but it was
you know she knew she didn't forget she
didn't forget
oh wait you would ask for it before Oh
months I would play it six months out
see Patty wouldn't do that February in
Japan like it could be my birthday
present you go okay
Patty one time sometimes you being a
real stickler she'd call me out on it we
used your bike didn't you we used to
make this trip every year to the King of
Prussia Mall on the dance of
Thanksgiving go shopping
get ideas for Christmas I found this
coat at the Gap that I want that I
[__] loved and wanted to start
flexing immediately I picked it out she
bought it right in front of me wouldn't
let me [__] have it until Christmas
yeah I was 13. I was like what are we
doing here I [__] saw you buy it yeah
but that's when you love the magic of
Christmas that's what it is that's where
you fall what are you talking about
that's different if you've got it on her
own I wouldn't have said nothing but I
was right there with her I was eating
Wok and Roll when she bought it me a
[__] break it was tight too I had to
wait until [__] and by that time I
didn't want to [__] wear it anymore
I wanted to add a spite it was a fall
jacket uh [__] little leather collar
one of those like like almost like a
Harley Davidson drums those things are I
don't understand that the leather with
like the cow like the oh get the [__]
dude some dudes I'm we're friends with
wear them and I'd say I don't I mean I
don't have leather coat leather jacket
confidence No I barely pull off a bomber
yeah no yeah no this was this was like a
preppy you know jacket was [__] sharp
[__] wouldn't that I snuck it out a
couple of times a couple of parties
yeah I gotta get a dry clean
what do you got T-Bone man Jeopardy
keeps their practice quizzes locked down
dude sure really oh yeah well you take
the quiz to get on the show online so
they they really Corner the testimony
should we try to get on the show no
yeah you're not getting on Jeopardy what
well I did I did [__] the Pod
what is patreon.com I mean if Trebek was
still around just to hang with him for a
little bit that Bozo Ken Jennings no
he's not doing it is he I don't know no
it's abroad all right it could be the
the blossom she's great a little trial
run here we got a couple topics you got
Sports theater plays in folklore you got
uh food and drink
I mean this is just Sports theater food
and drink
[Laughter]
fat asses for 3 000 please wait for this
last one it's really gonna blow your
mind animals
all right let's do animals all right all
right here we go uh the eastern gray
kangaroo can cover 25 feet in a single
leap and they are widespread in this the
country's smallest state you were just
about to say Australia yeah you thought
that was gonna be that easy
what is Melbourne no
dude
New Hampshire
eucalyptus what the [__] it's in
Australia you think there's kangaroos in
New Hampshire he said this country's
smallest state
New Hampshire is our smallest state not
this country we're in I thought you said
this country I did say this country as
in the country that you're referring to
oh Melbourne Australia I should would
have been the answer well the answer is
not the answer that was my guess
eucalyptus is a place I guess so man
probably a bunch of that [__] over there
all right sports for 900. uh in 2014
2015 and 2019 Novak Djokovic uh defeated
this switch Swiss player in the
Wimbledon final
uh Federer wait who is Roger Federer
yeah who was Roger Federer I tell you no
but this is the answer is the U.S open
that doesn't make sense
idiot Jesus Christ
well you ruined it way to blow it Toby
I'll take that 900 though
if you got it you got that on you what
are we doing here
don't talk to me talk to the idiots over
at trivia bliss.com
bleep that
um
you're the one doing it that's why it's
fun tell me got that
it's a pretty good time uh uh all right
this one's for man this is a one of the
original one of the OG questions that
started this show uh have you ever had
carpet in any of your bathrooms you know
I did yeah oh I did half one man purple
carpet wall two wall and the
Wilkes-Barre house my dad ruined it
shortly after if they're Indian one
night shortly after it was put in came
home a couple of Pops in them after a
softball game sure left a shower curtain
on the outside of the final yeah on the
wrong side of the fence Patty was
if you're you know looking back it was
probably about six feet of carpet
probably thirty two dollars the bathroom
was Tiny as [__] yeah but the foam and
that that Terry she hung it out in the
backyard and tried to dry it out and put
on it back dude you see the stain on the
bottom that water smelled like Grim
death in there for about six months so
she finally broke down and got rid of it
I'm getting rid of it feels good in the
piggies when you're in there
I think for like a week then after that
it's just every that ain't good no cause
like those rugs you put we were little
kids too I think I'm sitting all over
the floor you do it now nobody knew
there's uh because those rugs that you
have when you step out like the bath
mats they don't last that long
think of it now think about running the
air oh man I know yeah I hear you I
don't I can't do that yeah it's a tough
look man nobody's doing that now
I would hope not nobody
if you're listening comment or watch it
on YouTube comment or on patreon I would
love to know if people still have
[__] no [__] way I'm sure there's
some people out there got an older house
I mean they're not doing it now could
still be in there like your grandma
someone has someone's got to happen if
you moved into a place and it was and
there's carbon in the bathroom and you
don't wrap it up you're a dirt ball
because someone's [__] PP and
doo-doos are all over that oh I'm not
stepping on that
oh
being great
um
all right this one's from uh Robert
Redford's penis uh are you garbage if
you drink Gatorade with dinner even
though you haven't worked out in years
I'm a big gay I was for a very long time
a big Gatorade as a casual drinker as
you know
it's great it's so good
so so good we had the [__] machines
at 10 at College [__] I feel like
four [__] every flavor they had red
orange and yellow that may be a [__]
wild do your own punch you'd mix and
match no I do one of each one cup of
each because they were like the little
uh 12 ounce bangers so no they're
styrofoam so I do I remember that in
college I would do a Wild Cherry Coke or
Wild Cherry Pepsi or Cherry Coke
whatever it was each and then one of
each Gatorade and if it was fourth meal
I'd make chicken sandwiches out of the
chicken fingers on the hamburger buns
with a slice of American cheese and I
put down probably about 3 600 calories
at 11 p.m on a Tuesday you're just
sitting sweating red
hold on you would the cafeteria was open
till 11 o'clock yeah fourth meal whoa
yeah it was like a broken down menu
that's like it it was more like
school lunchy you know what I mean they
didn't have like dinner but they would
have like fries chicken tenders maybe
some Mott sticks or something like you
know bar food ass or would you get to
the hamburger rolls they had hamburger
rolls they were like you like you know
they had like just loose rolls oh maybe
I brought them I don't know
I say it all the time but that cafeteria
at widening University was [__]
unreal yeah it was so good
we used to have the little glass cups
fill up like [__] 15 of those with
orange drink
sit down yeah I was tough man
um all right let's do one more and then
we gotta Ripper up there sometimes here
uh
this one's from Spencer first time long
time never had one red let's get Let's
cross you off the list there Spence uh
is it garbage for me and my siblings to
be the beneficiaries of several family
members Wills because all of their kids
are trash that's tough
hold on so I understand the whole thing
read it over one more time
is it garbage is me and my siblings are
the beneficiaries of several family
members Wills because all of their kids
are trash so like
[__] hate them yeah oh [__] goody
two shoes oh yes well sorry like [__]
Spencer and Meredith
damn that's got dude Thanksgiving people
get murdered yes that's every forensic
file
you know I'm going to go back to night
school I'm getting my [__] together we I
just opened a bank account man
how would you feel about that I'd
[__] kill somebody
not out not even the month probably yeah
you need the money I get it but it's
also like just out of pure disrespect
I'm Gonna Make You Gotta really hate
your kids man to [__] pull that I'm
gonna make your cousin the beneficiary
of all of that's crazy your cousin's
gonna get all our money I assume that's
who he's talking about wow
and multiple this guy there's several
families his family probably stinks if
you think about it uh just shipping debt
your way yeah oh yes yeah you're the
[__] fall man that's [__] oh man
that's a home run
that's an awkward [__] Thanksgiving
everything so yeah you have to not talk
to those people they're hating you yeah
what are you doing come on over to my
new
but yeah
wrap it up though we do gang we love you
to death uh we'll see you next week
we'll be upstairs baby it's gonna be a
good time we love you see you out there
peace peace